hello my name is Linus Peterson and I'm
a student at lien stripping some
residents in biotechnology and my
question has to do with what happened
before the Big Bang will we ever know
what happened before the Big Bang and
what will it take for us to figure that
out
that's question I really like to be very
thank you
hi I'm Agnes I think your question is
one of the most popular questions what
happened before the Big Bang and of
course the short answer is we don't know
and we might never know but your bigger
question is well what could we learn to
find out so I think there are two parts
of it one is observational would we ever
discover something that's in the sky or
in some other way that was not expected
that would tell us what was there is
some left over from previous material
and the other one is theoretical can the
mathematicians make a theory and that
can be that survives test that explains
everything we know about say elementary
particles that we get from the Large
Hadron Collider and everything else we
know and still tells us something
definite about what happened before the
Big Bang now will this happen it's
calling the kind of a guess but I think
there will be a time when we have a
theory of everything many people are
working for this theory this would
probably require unifying the quantum
mechanics of ordinary particles with the
quantum mechanics of gravity that we are
only guessing about so we don't have a
quantum gravity theory now when we do
have one it will probably change our
understanding of space and time and so
it's possible that space and time are
actually a phony structure that they're
discrete in some way and that ideas of
things coming before other things may
even be changed when we come to quantum
gravity so when that happens and if we
ever get a theory that we like maybe
we'll be able to answer your question